women are women and that's that's the
problem is we keep telling men that
women aren't women oh you can find a
special woman who's not a woman no she's
still a woman and you know there's women
that are higher risk and lower risk like
I'd imagine and only fans model with a
chest tattoo I'd say that's much higher
risk than the Virgin bride right but
even the Virgin right you know I've
heard horror stories you know it's so
funny I've heard horror stories from men
that married virgins I've heard it all
can't really go to school to do what I
do I've interviewed so many hundreds of
people you know I've had consultations
with guys that tell me I married the
Virgin bride and it wasn't what you what
what you say it's cracked up to you